President Trump will speak at an indoor
event in Arizona today and that is one
of the most dangerous States for the
coronavirus since the president's Tulsa
rally two more campaign staffers have
tested positive and another complication
for the president face coverings are
mandatory in Phoenix that is where he
will be speaking we Jiang reports now
from the White House President Trump is
expected to address a crowd of 3,000
students for Trump in Phoenix all of
whom had to agree not to hold organizers
or the venue liable if they can track
Kovan 19 even as White House officials
downplay the threat of the virus
there is no second wave coming the
administration said yesterday it was
because of coronavirus that it needed to
extend a ban on immigration to protect
US jobs
and suspend certain work visas through
the end of the year following that
announcement the president plans to stop
by Yuma today to mark the completion of
200 miles of his border wall
highlighting his campaign promise to
stop illegal immigration meanwhile it is
his campaign relaunch that continues to
spark controversy because of comments
mr. Trump made so I said to my people
slow the testing down please the White
House insisted President Trump was
joking but when directly asked he did it
deny directing a slowdown did you ask to
slow it down if it did slow down frankly
I think we're way ahead of ourselves if
you want to know the truth and then
there was this rhetoric to describe the
virus I can name comes Lou
see use racist phrases like the palm
flew by the president doesn't the what
the president does do is point to the
fact that the origin of the virus is
China Kong flu is extremely to be clear
to be clear I think the media is trying
to play games with the terminology of
this virus weisia joins us now he's a
good morning so in that exchange we just
saw with White House press secretary
Kaley mcenany did she eventually get to
whether or not the president regrets
using that term come flu yeah she said
President Trump never regrets putting
the onus on China for the virus but she
could not explain how using come flu
accomplishes that since the phrase does
not refer to a place still she insisted
that it is the same as saying Chinese or
Wuhan virus and dismissed concerns from
asian-american advocacy groups who say
it is racist when an administration
official used the term back in March at
the time White House adviser Kellyanne
Conway said it is highly offensive Tony
I remember that exchange well we've you
thank you very much